(thunder crashing)
- [Narrator] A storm is
brewing in South Dakota.
- [Radio] Sorry I didn't
get that. Southwest 1772-
- [Narrator] And it's moving
swiftly into Minnesota,
bringing with it rain,
hail, thunder, and wind.
A mass exodus is taking place
from one social media website to another.
But there's still some
survivors left behind,
album shares, party pictures.
This one doesn't look any different.
The user is sent to a webpage,
and it's disguised in a coat
that makes it look normal,
but the last two letters
reveal its true identity.
They're prompted to install
a video player update.
(ominous music)
(glass cracking)
This unsuspecting
computer is now a zombie,
connected to a mesh of
other half dead machines
spread all throughout the planet.
A botnet known simply as...
(loud whooshing)
- [Robot] You are watching "DisrupTV."
- [Announcer] Congratulations. You won!
Congratulations. You won!
♪ Now, now, now, now ♪
♪ Now, now, now, now, yes ♪
- [Narrator] An antivirus
company announces a discovery.
(suspenseful music)
Typically URLs are hosted
on a single web server
through a single internet
protocol address.
If one is found to be malicious,
it's fairly easy to chop
it down from the root
by blocking the IP.
But these URLs are utilizing
a tactic known as fast flux.
In a fast flux network, the
IP address of the domain name
is constantly switched out,
making it near-impossible
to find the core of the infection.
Perfect for the first
stage of self-propagation
over the dates.
In this time period,
we see variants appearing that are created
from the original MySpace exploit.
Targets Skype,
targets Twitter,
(whistle)
makes its way onto the
Macintosh ecosystem.
It spreads not only through
social media messages,
but right under our noses.
An ordinary website.
You can download files from here.
Koobface covers the otherwise
safe download button
with an HTML IFrame.
This sends a PDF file to the user
that when opened, scans the computer.
It's searching for a
file transfer protocol.
If found, it will send out
a message to the other bots,
who will subsequently use the exploited
username and password to make
a new home within its victim.
With each newly infected host,
the botnet grows larger,
creating a decentralized
untraceable network
that turns left, turns
right, goes up, and goes down
on the whim of whoever
has the steering wheel.
- [Ron] (indistinct) with
how to protect your computer.
Dave?
- [Dave] Yeah Ron, it's really scary
how easily it can infect your computer.
In fact, we had a
computer expert show us...
(train rattling)
(lively music)
(indistinct broadcast)
- [Narrator] It's 1997
and the most popular
website in the world is...
- [Man] Yahoo!
- [Narrator] More than 17
million people use the site
every month to explore a new
frontier known as the internet.
But at 7:00 p.m. on Monday, December 8th,
Yahoo is hijacked.
(upbeat music)
Confronts anyone who opens the browser.
The message reveals that the
computer of every single person
who's visited Yahoo in the past month
has been infected with a worm.
And on Christmas day, in
less than three weeks,
the bomb will detonate
and destroy millions
of contaminated computer systems.
That is, unless the
hijacker's one demand is met.
Anger erupts, and over the following days,
protests break out on the
streets across the United States.
They set up camp outside
federal courthouses
and from New York to California
people call in to radio
stations to cry out the phrase,
in real life and in video games.
- [Radio Host] Do you
have anything else to say?
- [Radio Caller] Yes, free Kevin!
- [Radio Host] Oh!
- [Narrator] It's now just
one week until Christmas.
And most are asking...
(dramatic music)
He hoists himself up
and looks through the bars on his windows.
But Kevin isn't a terrorist.
He isn't a mafia boss and he's not here
because he wiretapped the NSA
or blackmailed FBI agents.
Authorities say he poses
an even greater danger
because with a single
phone call, they say,
he can dial into the NORAD and access
the nuclear arsenal of the
United States of America.
- [JFK] The advent of nuclear weapons
changed the course of the world.
- [Narrator] Kevin might
only be an innocent prankster
or Kevin could be the
world's most dangerous
cyber terrorist,
a man who has North
America at his fingertips.
To free or not to free,
that is the question.
(jaunty tones)
This is a Windows registry key.
And this is that same windows registry key
modified by Koobface.
When a computer wants
to connect to a website,
it goes through a domain
management system or DNS.
This is typically provided by
an internet service provider.
A VPN circumvents this by
building its own bridge
that handles the traffic toward
whatever website the user types in.
Koobface is doing something similar,
but instead of directing
traffic to the website
in its true form, it repaints road signs,
changes GPS directions,
and guides the user to
wherever it pleases.
(upbeat techno music)
YouTube, Wikipedia, PayPal,
all resolved to IP addresses employed
by the command and control center.
This is how the Koob makes its money.
Right there.
When that user clicked the link,
Koobface instantly shot his browser
through a number of affiliate
advertising networks.
Instead of the machine
sending HTTP GET to Google
as it normally does, an infected machine
sends HTTP GET to Koobface,
who responds with a list
of affiliated links.
It's only after receiving those links
that the machine correctly
sends HTTP GET to Google,
who then returns with the legit results.
The first result corresponds
to the first affiliate link
and when clicked, for just a
brief moment, an advertisement.
After that process, the used
affiliate link is scrubbed
and a new one takes its place.
These systems may offer two
bucks per a thousand users
that click the affiliate link.
Multiply that by hundreds of
thousands of infected bots
across the planet, clicking links all day,
and at this point, Koobface's
command and control center
is passively pulling in $38,000 per week.
(orchestral music)
The victim may now notice
that something feels off.
Their loading times are slower.
Toolbars keep appearing out of nowhere.
And just in time, a
helping hand is offered.
Similar to the Google
search, a response is sent
to Koob's command and control center.
It responds with a list of
antivirus software downloads,
picks one, and displays it on the desktop.
After the user pays,
their PC remains infected
and command and control
gets a paycheck.
We live in a world of bots.
But where do these
soulless beings come from?
Alan Turing, a 20th century mathematician,
creates the Turing test.
In the experiment, a human
has a text-based conversation
with a computer and another human.
If he can't tell who is the
computer and who is the human
then the computer has passed the test.
Now we've flipped this.
Instead of us, with the
human telling computers
apart from humans, computer
needs to figure out who's you
and who's me and who is it's robotic kin.
- So you are a robot.
- No, my name is Cleverbot.
- Yes, you are a robot and
your name is Cleverbot.
- I am a robot.
- Yes, I know.
- Together we are robots.
- I'm not a robot. I'm a unicorn.
- [Narrator] In the beginning,
Koobface uses a small portion
of manually created accounts
to spread initially.
But now, as the infrastructure grows,
it needs a way to create
thousands of fake accounts
to ensnarl thousands of more victims.
Completely Automated Public Turing-Test
to tell Computers and Humans Apart.
Normally CAPTCHA would be a brick wall
for an amateur bot program.
But Koobface has found
a clever work around.
First it sends the following
command to Facebook.
The login and password are
encoded via an encrypted scheme
that involves reading the letters,
their corresponding AC
values, and comparing that
to a successive string of
numbers from zero to one
to two to three to four to--
(chiming tone)
Encrypted becomes un-encrypted.
New account information is
sent to the social media site.
The social media site
responds with another packet
containing a blank bio, birthday,
favorite books, activities.
Koob auto-fills this with
randomly generated info
that feels just realistic enough.
Next the site will ask for CAPTCHA.
To circumvent this, the
CAPTCHA puzzle is mirrored
to the desktop of any
individual in its bot army.
Two things happen.
Their screen is unlocked
and the CAPTCHA for the
new minion is complete.
Koobface deploys this
scheme a number of times.
Millions of friend requests
are sent across Facebook
and the army grows ever larger.
Cyber investigators
uncover an irregularity.
The connection of interest
is located on servers
hosted by Coreix in the UK.
The data flowing in and
out of one of these servers
matches observed data by Koobface.
The command and control
centers are wiped out
and the bots are left
wandering without direction.
Hundreds of new command
and control centers appear,
which ushers in Koobface's peak
with an estimated 600,000
infected machines.
The unraveling of Koobface is delivered
through the very same websites
it previously exploited.
An Apache HTTP client is used to
control files to and from a web server.
For the most part, it can
be functioned anonymously
unless a specific option
is left untouched.
This option will drop breadcrumbs
that display to any
visitor what type of files
are being transferred to and
from the botnet on the daily.
(rat chewing)
This photo's metadata shows
it was taken with an iPhone
on September 15th, 2009.
This is a daily backup of the Koobface
command and control software.
Inside, an IP stands out.
This is programmed to automatically send
a daily SMS update to five numbers.
Updates that show exactly how much profit
the network is pulling in.
The numbers are searched.
One is found, an online
marketplace for vehicle sales,
license plate in full view.
Another market, selling sphynxes.
A name is registered on
a number of websites.
The same BMW is found on Flickr.
Also the cat.
One of the found email
addresses on a social media page
points to a corporate
email called MobSoft.
The website is defunct,
but the company details list an Anton K.
Job listings, the numbers on it,
both match the PHP found in Koob.
(intense music)
Their names are
cross-referenced with their
respective social media accounts,
and here they posted
their vacation pictures.
Publicly.
Facebook doxes their
full names and pictures.
They are dubbed Alibaba and 4.
And now in a rather anticlimactic peak,
the Koobface command and control
centers simply go offline.
From that point on to
our current day and age
Koobface's original
command and control center
has never been reactivated.
Alibaba and 4 are off the grid.
(orchestral music)
And the zombie army
remains dormant.
(laughing and shouting)
(fast-paced music)
- Good evening, citizens of the metaverse
and welcome to the Electronic
Simulation Showcase Show.
Today we're looking at
the sports car of at-home
virtual reality hardware; the Roto chair.
This gaming chair is specially designed
to increase immersion in
your favorite VR simulations.
Plug in your HMD cables into the grade A
cable management system.
When you turn your head in
game, the motorized chair
will turn your entire
body a full 360 degrees.
The Roto is equipped
with double rumble motors
on the bottom and backsides,
meaning every explosion,
every windstorm, will feel
like you're actually there.
Intense.
Comfort is the name of the game
when you're kicking back
and watching a film,
flying through the vast cosmos,
or shooting your way to victory.
With full padding, it's
like you're sitting
on an immersive cloud,
ready to reach the depths
of the metaphysical simulation or
virtual, virtual, virtual,
transconfigurational realities.
The Roto chair, the world's
first interactive VR chair.
(upbeat music)
(ethereal music)
- [Kevin] I joined a
bunch of phone phreakers
who were gathering for a party.
Something like two dozen people show up,
each one almost as much of a nerd
as the worst of a ham radio enthusiast.
The conversation inevitably gets around
to one of my favorite targets, COSMOS,
the Pacific telephone
mission system that could
bestow so much power on any
phreaker who could access it.
As we started talking,
I realized the building that
houses COSMOS is nearby.
The guard is a young guy.
I say, "Hey, how you doing?
"We're out late. I work here.
"I wanted to show my
friends where I work."
He says, "Sure, just sign in."
Doesn't even ask for an ID. Smooth.
We've been calling
departments and analyzing
phone company operations
for so long that we know
exactly where the COSMOS
employees work, room 108.
A folder on the wall
holds up sheets of paper
listing dial-up numbers
for every wire center
in Southern California.
Armed with this list
and log-in credentials,
I'd have the ability to
control any phone line
in Pacific Telephone's Southern
California service area.
- [Automated Voice] Hello.
- [Kevin] I can't believe our luck.
We should have left then,
but I spot a set of COSMOS manuals
and the temptation is irresistible.
I tell the guys, let's take
the manuals to a copy shop,
run off a copy for each of us,
then return the manuals
before people start
coming back to work in the morning.
It was the most stupid
decision of my early life.
We drive around looking for a copy shop
but can't find one, it's 2:00 AM.
So I take the manuals home with me.
But I have a bad feeling about them,
so I throw it all in some trash bags
and give them to my accomplice.
Tell him to throw them away or something.
- [Narrator] An unknown
teenager has hacked
a new network known as NORAD.
It's an organization that
provides aerospace warning
and protection for North America.
And this kid infiltrated the system
just to have a look around.
The move is so bold that it
inspires the film "War Games."
- Game, or is it real?
- Journalist John Markoff
gets in touch with Kevin.
He wants him to be part of his new book
on hackers named "Cyberpunk."
He's gained a reputation as a
master of social engineering.
It's the art of deceiving
people and just sharing valuable
and confidential information
for fraudulent purposes.
But he's not interested
in the money on offer.
He wants to maintain a low profile
so he refuses to be part of the book,
much to the displeasure of John Markoff.
On a hot summer's day in L.A.,
Kevin pulls out the
Stephen S. Wise Temple,
where he works as a receptionist.
In his rear view mirror, he thinks he sees
a group of three men following him
in a Ford Crown Victoria.
He pulls a U-turn and sure
enough, they do the same.
Kevin speeds down the I-405
and the car races after him.
Suddenly one of the men
places a cop car flasher
on the roof of the car and
now the sirens are crying out.
Kevin pulls over. The officers rush up.
They scream. Kevin is
dragged out, handcuffed.
His car is ransacked, but
there's no signs of any bomb.
- [Kevin] You're not gonna find it.
- [Narrator] He's hauled to the station.
The officers don't find a logic bomb,
but they know about a
crime Kevin committed.
A friend told the police everything.
He's sentenced 12 months in prison,
followed by three years
of supervised release.
He sits in the courtroom,
betrayed and alone.
His attorneys plead with a
judge that his hacking is
an addiction rather
than criminal behavior.
They say the young man needs
help, not a prison cell.
Kevin rises and pleads
his case to the judge.
By now he's a veteran in deception.
The judge agrees and orders
that Kevin serve his sentence
in a halfway house for those
with the compulsive disorders.
Kevin laughs as he's
listening to the ruling.
He was arrested for tricking
his way into a computer system,
and now he deceives
the judge into thinking
that he's the victim of his own crimes.
It's a few weeks until
supervised release ends
and the demon on his
shoulder is whispering.
He starts learning about Pacific Bell,
a telephone company based in California.
An idea appears.
If he gets caught, he'll be sent to jail,
but if he doesn't then he'd
have fooled the authorities
right under their noses.
(laughing and yelling)
Soon, he has all the passwords
and credentials he needs
to take control of the
company's voicemails.
(distorted female voice)
Kevin is on the run for two years.
He loses a hundred pounds.
When he learns that how a criminal walks
is the number one way they're recognized,
he puts pebbles in his
shoes to change his stride.
He uses over a dozen different names.
His favorite is Eric Wise.
(mellow music)
He begins a crime spree that infiltrates
the world's biggest companies,
Nokia, Fujitsu, etc.
The companies say the
damage from the hacks totals
300 million US Fiat.
Kevin sips his coffee
as he reads the paper
and suddenly a chill
passes down his spine.
FBI agents take their positions
outside the house in California.
They see their target sitting inside,
burst in and draw their weapons.
And the man denies that
he's Kevin Mitnick.
He's a Middle Eastern immigrant.
Doesn't even own a computer.
More than 2000 kilometers away in Seattle,
Kevin throws his paper to the ground,
his name emblazoned on the front
page of the New York Times.
Kevin is adamant the stories
and the articles are lies.
He never hacked into NORAD
or wiretapped the NSA.
But if you believe Kevin, then
you shouldn't trust anything
you've heard so far about Kevin.
He takes on mythical status overnight.
A little known prankster is now
public enemy number one of cyberspace.
Kevin walks the streets
of Seattle in a daze.
Many of the passing faces on the sidewalk
seem to be staring straight back at him.
He hears the faint sound
of a helicopter in the sky
and feels his heart beginning to thump.
No one seems to notice the helicopter,
but they do notice Kevin.
He hurries into the courtyard
of an apartment complex
and uses the tall trees as cover,
peering through the leaves.
Kevin tosses a package into the bushes
and bursts into a full-on sprint.
He gets away.
But from what?
One of America's top
cyber security experts is
finalizing plans to leave for
a ski vacation the next day.
And suddenly his own computer is hacked.
His phone rings.
(phone ringing)
- [Male Voice] Your security
technique will be defeated.
Your technique is no good.
- [Narrator] To someone like him,
the attack and subsequent
taunts are an act of war.
(suspenseful tones)
He sets up a series of
stealth monitoring posts
and creates his own software
to track the hacker.
He waits in silence until
the alarm is triggered.
He traces the intruder to a computer modem
connected to a cellular telephone,
somewhere on the east coast.
A man steps out onto his balcony
in Raleigh, North Carolina,
and suddenly a chill
passes down his spine.
The FBI agents take their
positions outside the house.
They see their target sitting inside.
Journalist John Markoff
watches from the street.
The agents burst in
and draw their weapons,
but find nothing.
The man furiously denies
that he's Kevin Mitnick.
He's so convincing the FBI
agents are about to leave,
but then an agent notices an
old ski jacket in the cupboard.
He empties the pockets
and out falls a pay stub.
Legacy Media pitches up
their circus tents outside.
- Most wanted computer
hacker is behind bars.
- [Narrator] Kevin shares
one large holding cell
with 60 other inmates.
He doesn't eat for two days
because the food isn't kosher.
Inside, all eyes are
fixed on the defendant.
Kevin is charged with
14 counts of wire fraud,
eight counts of possession of
unauthorized access devices,
interception of wire or
electronic communications,
and causing damage to a computer.
When Kevin is led away from the court,
Tsutomu calls out from the front row.
Kevin looks back at his nemesis,
the one man who finally saw through
the lies and deceptions to find him.
He nods, says nothing, and walks away.
His appeals for bail are turned
down by every single court
in the US, including the Supreme.
Kevin says the beefed up
charges are an injustice
and his treatment is a denial
of his constitutional rights.
But why won't anyone believe him?
He has one last idea,
but then a group of
officers storm into the cell
and throw him into solitary confinement.
- Might change a lot of
things in a negative way.
I mean, he's trying so hard
to at least get a trial,
and then this comes up.
- [Man] Yahoo!
(somber music)
- [Narrator] Christmas Day
passes without incident.
The hack on Yahoo was a hoax carried out
by members of the Free Kevin movement.
There was no logic bomb.
After four years of prison
and solitary confinement,
Kevin pleads guilty to
four counts of wire fraud,
two counts of computer fraud,
and one count of illegally intercepting
a wire communication.
- [Kevin] I didn't think of
the consequences when I was
engaging in this behavior, I just did it.
I'd copy the code, store it on a computer,
and go right on to the next,
without even reading the code.
And that, complete different
motivation of somebody
who's really out for financial
gain or a foreign country
or a competitor trying
to obtain, you know,
information like economic
espionage, for instance.
- You know, I hate to suggest
the waste of your talent
but as I listen to you, I think
you'd make a great lawyer.
- Well, I don't know, if
you're convicted of a felony
if they'd allow you to
be admitted to the bar.
- [Narrator] Kevin Mitnick
is released from prison
after nearly five years.
When Kevin was on his crime
spree, his hacking exploits
seemed like mythology
to the outside world.
But by the time the sun hits his face,
the world needs his skills.
So soon after his release, he
testifies before the Senate
and advises on how to better protect
computer systems from attacks.
(gentle music)
- [Davis] So I really like sleep.
And the thing that I do like about sleep
is that it's an alternate reality.
Nothing is impossible in sleep.
When you dream, you can
fly and you can also die.
You can laugh and you can cry.
You can sing,
but you won't notice a
thing because you're asleep.
I feel like sleep is a
transportation to a new world
for eight or less hours,
or maybe even more.
Sleep is very nice to have.
I feel like it's a privilege
because some other people,
they don't have the access to sleep
because of things like insomnia.
So I feel like you should
never take sleep for granted
because if you stay up,
I think you're gonna
stay up for a long time.
Sleep is very good for the body
and it's awesome.
- [Robot Voice] I was disrupted,
ba doop boop bap ba deep boop.